[Musique]
oui
enaco dj voilà c'est tout pour moi
ok alors ouais ouais
oui à donner du rythme au quai ouais
ouais ok alors oui oui mais je sais
c'est le truc ça revient ça regarde bien
j'ai juste c'est la première phrase qui
est rude si j'ai préparé j'ai vraiment
réjoui ces bourses et ses hommes voilà
mais on ouvre on va en guerre alors
voilà je suis papa merci merci c'était
prévu ça y est je j'ai quatre enfants
merci merci
ses quatre enfants ouais c'est c'est
pour ça que je me suis remis à 45 ans à
faire du sport
de détente de la boxe thaïlandaise
parce que 7h20 pour moi cet ordre c'est
au petit déj pour vous c'est quoi le
biberon exactement merci exactement donc
j'en ai 4 maxime deux ans donc au
biberon
elle est où ma main maman elle est
partie au travail
elle est aux mamans ben maman les partis
au travail en bus
doit-on bible est allé ou maman maman
les parties avec mamie faire du skate au
skatepark parce que ça va mieux en ce
moment donc elles sont parties aux au
parvis de la défense faire un peu de
roller elle est aux mamans mois va pas
revenir
elle est où maman maman est décédée dans
un accident d'hélicoptère et juste avant
de mourir elle a dit au pilote
je suis bien content de partir comme ça
je verrai plus tard vieilles têtes de l
et aux mamans
voilà donc ça c'est maxime deux ans on
peut l'applaudir
ensuite j'ai j'ai sophie cinq ans alors
elle le matin ces cinq ici rennes elle
est blonde
enfin et c'est ma famille les normands
ce pour ça enfin bref voilà elle me
ressemble pas de haut niveau des cheveux
et donc elle voilà lé plus le matin
petite sirène donc par exemple
voilà voilà voilà même et ont un peu
plus ouais les polyphonies corses et est
donc hélas toujours un souci parce que
parce que baala se coller les sens c'est
le principe du chocolat chaud sophie
l'a16 et le mans bête et le pomper l'eau
mombet droit est donc pour elle des
objets ils sont vivants
je suis je suis je dit dominé deux
minutes je vais parler avec le donc toi
la chaise tu sais la dernière faute chez
entreprendre la prochaine fois je te
pète un pied et et toi le pantalon je
vais tirer si fort que même les
chaussettes et vend pas trop connaître
ces bons sophie tu tu peux voir ton
chocolat souffle
charlotte tu peux tu peux arrêter de
faire des saltos dans le salon s'il te
plaît tu te trompes papa ce n'est pas un
salto mais à une roulade un sale tour
mais les deux bon écoute tu tues tu vas
prendre ton sac de piscine est allé le
vide et parce qu'à l'intérieur il ya ta
serviette qui fait des saltos merci
charlotte wells et c'est maître capello
ceux qui connaissent voilà elle me
reprend et puis la dernière
juliette juliette il est 7h 29 tu peux
te laisse te plaît 12 ans juliette
7h48 non mais vous êtes sérieux dans
cette femme il ya plus de jus d'orange
frère
d'abord je suis pas ton frère
et ton frère il ya deux ans il arrive
même pas au niveau du frigo ok frère
voilà et donc ce que je vous propose
comme que c'est c'est de chacun on va on
va partager la la salle en 4 ça vous dit
oui à cette façon vous êtes obligé donc
ici ici je vais me faire simple les
maximes sava et maxime vous me faites
voilà très bien voilà il y en a un
un deux trois ouais très bien c'est pas
mal ils sont bons
ici tient ouais vous avez des tête d'ado
non mais vous êtes vous êtes sérieux
frère je laisse ça non mais vous êtes
sérieux frère
très bien c'est pas mal ici ici on est
on est au troisième vingt donc vous
souvenez elle va dire papa tu te trompes
ce n'est pas une roulade mais un salto
oui mais je change de textes adaptés
ouais ccc interactif même moi je suis
interactif à l'intérieur je situe fait
je te dis des choses mais c'est pas
vraiment moi qui t'ai dis donc
ça marche ça n'a pas très bien compris
c'est pareil et ici la petite sirène
ok très bien
alors et ça c'est tous les matins à 7h20
par le soir pour qu'il s'endorme je ne
rejoue une berceuse quoi je suis sérieux
non je suis pas sérieux
[Musique]
oh
ou want candy
[Musique]
c'est long
quand bien même si j'ai fait combien la
tête et limite la jda combien dix
minutes
non sans déconner je fais vite et je
fais vite je fais je l'aï tapé en 30
secondes
d'accord d'accord moi je fais vite je
fais vite chacune est déjà d'accord je
vais jeter vite j'ai fait on remonte le
temps
combien de temps encore mon frère
combien de temps encore ma soeur combien
de temps encore combien de temps encore
attendre
[Musique]
le
e
la feta
karima
au parc voisin victimes de la misère
victime de la justice persécuté par les
guerres persécuté par le fisc comme on
tend pas mon frère quand même temps par
ma soeur du côté de mon grand père de ma
nièce par alliance habitat
green zone est à la croisée des bases et
cause elle gagne un petit morceau de 2
c'est juste un perso je finissais trop
tard d'une des nombreuses et causait
colas et je finis au finish venu visiter
quand c'est plus profond en cas d'accord
je cause que j'ai causé la pause quelque
chose si je n'ai pas tapé jeu trois
causes vous remettez quiz et toi c'est
ton top de sa wii loin du puy du fou et
là c'est à vous africa des mois et des
mois parce que tu as des africains super
tiens je te laisse la guitare a fait
qu'à aller tous ensemble on finissait
6,2 secondes africains à aller plus fort
plus fort des africains les samoans de
la sergent garcia
elie cantona
kaba diawara mohamed sall un bal pop à
une bd sousa
et kansas a fait état au pull qui n'a
dans une simca avec madonna et lady gaga
d'allada la percée
[Musique]
tommy gainey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]